I've been struggling with an idea
recently that I was thinking maybe you'd
be able to help me out with basically in
a recent interview you talked about how
myth is meant to reconcile inherent
contradictions in reality right but but
I'm sort of stuck between two
mythological or psychoanalytic ideas
that I think are both really important
but they seem to have a inherent
contradiction within them that I've been
trying to figure out so on one hand you
have this idea that there's times in
your life where you have to identify
things in yourself that are insufficient
or there's a problem somehow that you
have to kind of have a controlled burn
or like a Phoenix like transformation
where you discard part of yourself that
doesn't fit or is not working but then
on the other hand you have talked about
this this Union idea where as you become
really when you get older you mature by
reincorporating things about yourself
that you lost when you were younger or
that you know you're trying to integrate
your shadow or you're trying to find
parts of your personality that that
maybe you've been rejecting and trying
to figure out how to bring them into
into the folder in the hole so he's got
this quote that I really like which is
I'd rather behold and good right right
so so on one hand you may identify
something as a problem and you want to
get rid of it or burn it off but then on
the other hand it seems like the the
path to being stronger is to figure out
how to put everything together so
there's that there's a one of the things
young wrote about in his works on
alchemy was an explanation of the prime
alchemical dictum which was solve a
coagula which meant dissolve and
integrate right so so imagine this
imagine that imagine you had a fairly
hostile father who was not very well
controlled in his aggression decent
person other than that but let's say
that and so your reaction is I'm never
going to be aggressive and so you built
a like a moral structure that's part of
your personality and there's
ability floating around outside of that
did you you've denied an ethical you've
denied any ethical what would you say
you've stripped the idea of aggression
of any ethical utility whatsoever okay
so what happens this burns off and then
that comes back up now you still have to
integrate it so it's associated in some
sense with Nietzsche's ideas morality as
cowardice because one of nature's most
trenchant critiques of traditional
morality let's say is that most of what
passes for morality isn't morality
it's just cowardice it's not that I'm a
good person and I don't hurt you it's
that I'm afraid to hurt you and because
I don't want to admit that I'm afraid to
hurt you then I say I'm moral because
then I can mask my essential fear and
cowardice in a guise of morality and
that happens far more often than you
would think because harmless and moral
are by no means the same thing so some
of what you're burning off you can sit
and this is where Freud was such a
genius I think is because he
concentrated on aggression and sexuality
which are perhaps the two most difficult
parts of a personality to integrate said
that the the hyper simplified morality
stops you from tapping into deeper
recesses of your psyche and it's partly
because there are primal forces it's not
surprising that you don't want to have
anything to do with them that you stay
away from situations where they might
make themselves manifest but the problem
is by denying the worst in yourself in
that manner suppressing it you preclude
the possibility of the best because no
one can be a good person without
integrating their capacity for
aggression because without that capacity
aggression you cannot say no because no
means if you really say it no means
there isn't anything that you can do to
me that will make me change my mind or
or conversely it means I will play for
higher stakes than you will and unless
you've got your aggression integrated
there isn't a chance you can say that
and if you did no one
would take you seriously because they'd
know it was just a show so one of the
most useful things that Jung did I think
was to work on this idea of the
integration of the shadow because he was
really interested in the idea of evil
right especially working with trying to
parcel out what happened in Nazi Germany
and during the Second World War
what do you do with the part of you
that's aggressive and and potentially
malevolent do you just crush it that's
the super ego response in some sense do
you just put it behind you so to speak
is that a possibility or do you admit to
its existence and bring it into the game
and that's see for Freud in some sense
morality was super-ego clamping down on
the it'd and they were fundamentally
opposed both young and Piaget had a
different idea and I think they were
right it's like no no you invite the bad
guys out to play and so you're an
aggressive hockey player but it's
disciplined aggression that makes you
gives you access to the whole source of
energy you wouldn't otherwise have and
then with regards to sexuality it's like
well untrammeled promiscuity doesn't
constitute a virtue but neither does
unavoidable virginity right in fact I
think that's worse because it also masks
itself with virtue it's like well you
should be able to you should be able to
do things that you wouldn't do that's
that's like the definition of a
genuinely moral person they could do it
but they don't and then that's not
cowardice and so that's you burn off the
things that get in the way of that
integration so when you say dissolve and
integrate it be a good way to sort of
bring the two ideas together that the
burning off and the difficult process is
necessary because the elements of
yourself are structured together in a
rigid way that is not working properly
and that's what happens to Geppetto in
the belly of the whale he's so caught in
his presuppositions that he can't escape
right and so Pinocchio represents the
new force so it's very interesting so
when you watch Pinocchio try to rescue
him
the first thing Geppetto does is confuse
Pinocchio with a fish because he wants
something to eat
but Pinocchio is better than something
to eat because he could rescue him so he
doesn't need to eat and then Pinocchio
wants to make a fire in Geppetto objects
because he's gonna burn up all the
furniture it's like we don't need the
damn furniture if we're getting out of
the whale you know and so so Geppetto
and and he's old so that that that's
that that's the rigid structure that's
the old year that has to die off before
the new year can be born it's a forest
fire that allows for new growth and and
that's how those things are put together
and to see and it's useful to know too
because if you burn something off you
might think well there's nothing left
it's like that's not true if it's dead
wood then you have room for new growth
and you want to be doing that on a
fairly regular basis that's the that's
that's the snake that sheds its skin and
transforms itself right that's that's
the death and resurrection from a
psychological perspective it's exactly
the same idea now we don't know the
upper limit to that right because we
don't know what a person would be like
if they let everything that they could
let go let go and only let in what was
seemly let's say but you can see that's
funny we don't know that to some degree
you can see people very firm you can see
people start to do that without that's
not an rare experience and people
improve very rapidly they can improve
their lives very rapidly a lot of its
low-hanging fruit like if you just stop
doing really stupid things that you know
are stupid your life improves a lot so
and it frees you up it also means
there's a there's an element there
that's also associated with pride
because people tend to take pride in who
they are and that's a bad idea because
that stops you from becoming who you
could be because if you're proud of who
you are you won't let that go when it's
necessary you won't step away from it
you know and then you end up being your
own parody something like that that's
also a very bad idea you want to be
continually stepping away from your
previous self and so big and I guess
part of that too is that you you have to
decide you know are you are you order or
you chaos or you the process that
mediates between them and if you're the
process that mediates between them you
you are the thing that transforms and
that's the right attitude for human
being because that's what we are we're
the thing that voluntarily confronts
chaos and transforms that's what we are
and so for better or worse you know
that's our deepest biological essence
you might say and so you can let things
go if you know that there's more growth
to come so